it's that time again to talk to you
about the latest games in new releases
and this week we get beta access and
lots of indie games I hope you didn't
spend all your cash in that steam summer
sale let's begin with the beta you've
been waiting for destiny pre-ordering
the game gives you beta access on the
17th as humanity's guardian of the last
city on earth you and Peter Dinklage
must explore the ancient ruins of our
solar system from the red dunes of Mars
to all those lush jungles on Venus that
you were taught about school defeat your
enemies explore ancient ruins and put
humanity back on top of the food chain
better late than never you have until
the 17th to pre-order now let's check
out 10 tons crimson land a dual stick
top-down shooter the game boasts an
arsenal of 30 weapons and 55 perks and
if that ain't enough for you there's a
60 mission campaign with three difficult
settings and five survival gameplay
modes with dedicated leaderboards for
single-player and to the 4 player co-op
oh you're going to be busy for a while
it's out on ps4 July fifteenth also this
week Mega Man Sonic and gunstar heroes
collide this explosive cartoon adventure
freedom planet this combat based
platform adventure picks a spunky speedy
dragon girl and her friends against an
alien attack force just like the classes
the boss fight begins July 19
also this week we get Neil Gaiman's
adventure game wayward manner you play
as a dead guy scaring the bejesus out of
people to get out of your house and find
out who your killer is can you handle it
like it starts caring July fifteenth
finally build your guns and gear grab
some friends and shoot your way through
the randomly generated city of
ravensdale the game is set at a medieval
metropolis where diesel-powered night's
clash with the orcs for control over the
city districts lightning arcs the cross
pits of bubbling goop and jet-assisted
assaults tear through the streets with
pure saturated carnage goop it up July
seventeenth for further details visit
gamespot's new releases page release
dates are based on retailer listings and
are subject to change see you next week